well moving and shaking this hour the
wolf of Wall Street the new Martin
Scorsese film that required actors to
learn some different side of investing
Leonardo DiCaprio stars was Jordan
Belford a real life broker who was
convicted of stocks wiggling last night
the movie hell did he work from here and
we talked to two of the cap Rios
co-stars who got a feel for the business
by talking to legit brokers if we were
playing people you know about a real
story of people involved in stocks you
know I would take any any assurance to
make sure i was you know learning
everything that I could immersing myself
as much as possible and we learned quite
up quite a bit they were really open
with us and letting us see what their
day-to-day operations were like I talked
to some salesman and I was just picking
out things and then I talked to people a
day then talking to sugarcoat it what up
but you'd hear them you could see what
they were kind of fibbing about you like
anyway service did amalgamation made up
a rap out of all that well what does
that immersion acting something like
like it like they've got they go and
they go into trading floor I think that
I think the notion I think that's a
great point right the notion that the
legit brokers are really different from
the bucket shop brokers going on some
level you're making the phones ring
you're trying to get a sale done I've
seen guys all firms of all kinds engaged
in some of these things i'm anxious to
movie because the book the wolf of Wall
Street was really and I hope it works
and what was interesting though was
there were some other some other
comments made at that premiere that
where they talked about you know what do
they do with their own money what about
investing right themselves and the all
the actors or most of the actors were
like well you know what I don't trust
any of these Wall Street guys I'm very
conservative I'm gonna put my money in
bonds and I'm not going to Lenny these
any of these guys gang gamble that money
away and that's kind of a general
feeling i think in hollywood of how Wall
Street is what and when people come into
money as actors will do and just
suddenly and lump sums after some
struggling exactly they can come in big
size it's a hard thing to manage fun
absolutely alright same for athletes do
well the wolf of Wall Street opens
Christmas Day